will is not doing well at all he does
have Duke to win it all he has
northeastern Iowa and Montana in his
final four in the great comedian great
actor Will Ferrell joins us on the
program good morning will
good morning Dan how are you what was
your strategy filling out your bracket
well here's the thing because I heard
you on one of your shows and correct me
if I'm wrong but you you had expressed
consternation that you don't necessarily
enjoy filling out your bracket that is
real-time dentistry right yeah because
it's now you know a 512 game is
basically a pick'em now yeah okay I have
the same consternation I find it very
stressful so I sat down with my
assistant Carolina and she helped me
pick out my bracket and it looks it and
as we started to go through the picks on
like Carolina you're killing me this is
disastrous or it's going to be one of
the greatest brackets ever and so far I
mean when you have G Webb knocking out
Virginia in the first round yeah yeah
and FD you go into the sweet 16 you know
you know something's either I mean this
was either a drop the mic moment you
know walk-off home on you guys would
have talked about me you know forever
but do you know the only person you're
beating is spot on his slot on and he's
your rival in Los Angeles right because
Slaton just wrote Zion and who do you
think will win
he didn't fill out any other teams in
the bracket okay so I know I'm gonna be
him yes I mean there's still a chance at
Duke
there is yeah but when you have engineer
Montana that Duke Montana match and an
Iowa against northeastern where are you
right now I'm in Los Angeles but Dan let
me ask you this I am I still you you
guys don't think any less of me right
I'm still I'm still fos there's there's
no way we could think less of you friend
of the show yeah I'm getting a new
studio just happen I announced it
yesterday and by the middle to late part
of April we will have a new man cave and
were located it's not very far from this
man cave I can send you renderings if
you'd like are they turning the old man
cave back into a yoga studio uh it was a
dance studio but yeah they were okay but
I don't know if they're turning it back
into then but when you travel and I
didn't know if I could ask you this and
and of course this is live so I'm
putting you on this appointment okay
yeah I wanted to have a roll out of all
the great memories we've had on this
program in the last year nine years
everything that's happened on the the TV
show in the man cave
and I started to wonder and I go you
know what who would be perfect for
singing the song memories yeah I just
thought thank God you didn't save a lot
on no no no I wasn't gonna do that but I
I just thought and I'm putting you on
the spot because you gave us dust in the
wind and you know one of the great great
performances I listen to it all the time
and I don't know I just thought maybe
you singing memories as we did this roll
out as everybody is cheering
I be happy to do that when when the time
is right when when do you think the time
would be right because we're our last
show is next Wednesday oh I don't know
if there's that much pressure on you but
maybe if you get together with Streisand
and she could help you a little you had
to do it now
I just once again okay I just yeah
thinking out of the box because we were
going down our memories greatest
memories of all time and you I think are
number one on the list when Ron Burgundy
came in you know that's right when he
came in off the street yes and spent a
couple hours with you guys
yes and he had a great time and I
thought you know what if we did he seem
like he did and come back I haven't seen
him since but he's very polite very
professional I think he did not enjoy
the treatment of Fritzi Wow why Donna
yeah you did you did show up you got hit
in the in the testicles by Fritzi
unflinching all has a big target they're
on ronberry that was malicious and to
embarrass them and then you were out on
the street you had your doughnuts and
your B right and my 40 yeah then the
fact that no one stopped to think nope
that's Ron Burgundy and this was yeah
the biggest movie and and you're coming
in it you know 8:15 in the morning with
beer and don't like six cars went by you
people
so it just speaks to my magnetism as a
as an actor yeah and yeah and to that
character no no you were you were only I
remember I'm sitting next to will and
then I I would ask him a question as if
he's will and he'd go no no no thank you
you were dead that was your Daniel
day-lewis moment you were so Daniel
day-lewis to Lincoln has nothing on Will
Ferrell to Ron Burgundy
Ron was concerned because you know if
you're a fan of the show there's a lot
of there's a lot of look-ins
occasionally and Ron never knew if he
was going to be on camera so he didn't
want anyone to see behind the curtain
yeah and then you know he would have a
makeup person come out and then reglue
his mustache like every every segment
like every 10 minutes they'd come out
and go
let me reglue your mustache and how Ron
Burgundy's podcast it's doing very well
yes and he's uh yeah he's a boy he
finally has an outlet he finally he's
not he's not quite sure how it works
he thought at first that it would be
taped either reel-to-reel or on cassette
tape and they'd have to just drop it off
at demos houses he doesn't really
realize you know how the internet works
and things like that but he's just
excited there's a platform for him to
talk about various topics but doesn't he
have Angie Dickinson on every week every
podcast he wishes he had RuPaul all
right yeah yeah I like that uh your are
you at your house right now or um I'm
I'm at my house I'm getting ready to
take the kids to school we are and
within we are taking them out early to
go to go see the games in Anaheim to see
my saga oh oh I thought you were going
to go see Mike Trout no no no okay all
right so you're gonna go techne we could
swing by after the after the two
basketball games
now did you buy ticket how does that
work when Will Ferrell I bought tickets
yes I went I went through I did go
through my agents who were able to
contact the fine folks at CBS okay and
we were able but we did we did purchase
our tip tickets try these through the
Viacom Network CBS true are you are you
gonna be like great seats like would you
be bothered if you walked in and you go
are you kidding me like I'm sorry yeah
yeah I'll make a huge steak and I'll you
know I'll probably do a play would place
it in the seats for a while and just go
guys let's get out of here
and make sure we're on camera what
happens why don't you cause an incident
today I actually I actually had a
thought because it's in Anaheim it's I
don't think it's gonna sell out
necessarily it'll be probably pretty
full but I was thinking I could just
walk up to the gate and just get
nosebleeds and hopefully get on camera
that way sitting way up at the top
that's kind of a move couldn't you wear
your Jackie moon here I don't I I guess
like I think that's why I think that's
one of the few costumes I do have Jackie
moon what weight do you have so you had
the burgundy you have that job that one
I have that one framed you got to keep
Talladega Nights yep I got it I got a
couple of the driving suits blades of
glory yep I have some ski outfit I have
that one framed okay stepbrothers did
you really have anything not really
that's yeah just a lot of t-shirts yeah
and then you kept the sneakers from old
school I have a Crystal Gayle t-shirt I
held on and then you have the tennis
shoes from old school the right ones
which which I wore to one of the shows
yes you did and it stuck him right my
face as if to say you want these but you
can't have these for the man cave what
do you wish you had that you didn't keep
well I wish I had that I didn't keep you
got the Elm do you have the elf costume
no I don't that would have been a good
one actually I know how do you let that
go well because you know this one could
be the end okay when did you know that
elf was gonna be a hit the first time I
watched it with an audience yeah but but
prior to that moment it was there was
yeah
it was touch and go yeah yeah pretty
just wanted me to remind you and me
angels are in Oakland so it might be a
little tougher to go to
well there's always Southwest we could
get a flight orange carrying when's the
last time you took the family on a
commercial flight uh we're actually
going this weekend to Deer Valley on a
commercial flight yeah sure
how does that work though do they say
coach and then you sit in first class
all right my wife and the kids yes sit
in coach okay and then we have we have a
schedule for visitation they head
rotating come they can come say hi to me
every hour on the hour and at the half
hour but do you you take up two seats
though like you have to have are you
ever confused for another celebrity I
pick um I I you know the Chad Smith
sometimes happens yeah drummer for the
Red Hot Chili Peppers but you guys have
been seen together
drumming confuse for each other but I
think him a lot more for me than
vice-versa
yeah if he couldn't perform an Anthony
Kiedis says her FLE says hey would you
fill in and would you be able to pull it
off maybe you like lip-synching but like
drums Center yeah yeah I would I would
reiterate to them that I'm not a
professional drummer and like but yes if
they had like a track ready to go you
know I would have I'd be happy to fake
my way through to our concert well safe
travels enjoy the games with the kids
nice that you spend a little time with
them for change and extend and what what
do i get if i win
bracket i get a certificate it's
mathematically impossible for me to win
right yeah at this point but don't think
that way but yes you have no chance of
winning okay okay you know I'm doing my
bracket next time because I believe last
year I was in the top five there for a
while you weren't gonna finish yeah yeah
you did well it was pretty exciting and
how's your soccer team I should you know
I gotta ask those these yeah you got we
are
to an amazing start we're number one in
the last 10 points elas went three wins
of the tie l AFC L AM see that's we play
San Jose Saturday could you ever be a
player coach I was are you kidding me
yeah I mean I'm not I'm 51 so I couldn't
do it right now you could be as far as a
goal here that would be a goalie
yeah it's true remember I wonder if I
could start a game at least for the
first two minutes they'd let me start a
game I kind of look into that but you
were talented enough to play all
positions in in bring training baseball
will yeah I gotta believe it you could
be out there and put on a uniform and be
in there for just a little you're the
owner I think it would I think it would
be good a lot of people all right well
thanks for joining us as always
safe travels and and we'll talk to you
soon take care
all right that's Will Ferrell for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]